soeben hat sich die schleswig
holsteinische bildungsministerium karin
prien zu wort gemeldet von der cdu und
fordert ein handyverbot in
gremiensitzungen
sie bezieht sich auf die information und
die berichte hier bei uns in bild live
wörtlich seit einiger zeit werden
regelmäßig
kurzmitteilungen und details über
äußerungen bei bild live veröffentlichen
da könne man auch die gremiensitzungen
gleich gut im live im fernsehen
übertragen gute idee frau kann ich nur
sagen denn es geht darum transparenz zu
schaffen es werden wichtige
entscheidungen getroffen für die zukunft
unseres landes und es ist gut dass man
weiß was hinter verschlossenen türen
passieren
oder der vorstoß von frau prien hat sich
vor einigen wochen ja schon einmal
gemacht der ist ja wirklich absolut
thüringer straßen auch in einem anschlag
auf die demokratie absolute das waren
das waren wirklich worte die waren
völlig unangemessen wir haben es aber
auch jetzt mit einem törichten vorschlag
zu tun frau prien will offenbar ihre cdu
zu einer verbots partei machen nicht zu
vergessen wir sehen eine union die
natürlich die wahl nicht gewonnen hat
sie hat die wahl verloren und das
problem was frau prien offenbart ist
dass sie mit dieser erosion der macht in
ihrer partei nicht ganz klar kommt und
sie sitzt auf einem irrglauben auf zu
glauben mit einem handy verbot könne man
in der heutigen zeit die kommunikation
zwischen politikern und beispielsweise
medien verhindern die ist ja absurd also
wer etwas mitteilen möchte der tut das
auch auf welchem wege auch immer aber
bleiben wir beim thema transparenz es
geht hier darum eine regierung für
deutschland zu bilden 80 millionen
bundesbürger wollen gerne wissen wer
wird der nächste bundeskanzler und
natürlich ist es auch aufgabe der medien
genau zu sehen was passiert in welcher
sitzung da kann man nicht mit einem
verbot kommen sondern da geht es
vollkommen richtig um das thema
transparenz und da ist so viel
transparenz nötig wie nur geht und es
ist ja auch ein bisschen schizophren in
anderen bereichen werden whistleblower
gefeiert auch von der politik sie jetzt
diese facebook geschichte und hier wird
es so verpönt ja frau prima offenbar sie
tut da einen dienst an ihrer partei wenn
sie solche absurden forderungen
aufstellt ich auch das gegenteil ist der
fall also sie trägt dazu bei das
eigentlich genau dieses bild was viele
viele menschen von politikern haben das
sind irgendwelche zimmern etwas aus
gemauschelt wird dieses bild verfestigt
sie eher mit genau diesem vorstoß also
ich kann nur sagen frau prien will die
cdu offenbar zu einer verbots partei
machen ist mit diesem vorstoß auf dem
wie in der schule handyverbot das ist in
der tat ein skurriler vorschlag muss man
sagen denn wir haben darüber gesprochen
da findet auch ein poker statt und
natürlich möchten wir wissen und hat die
bevölkerung ein recht darauf zu wissen
wer gibt da wem was wofür wird das eine
oder das andere eingehandelt
[Musik]